welcome to the second annual Hillsdale
College Constitution Day celebration I'm
David Bob director of hills dales LNP
Kirby jr. center for constitutional
studies and citizenship we are glad that
you've all joined us here today as we
gather together with more than 60,000
citizens from all 50 states who have
registered for this program as the
constitutional convention drew to a
close and just before the delegates
signed the document on September 17 1787
Benjamin Franklin wandered out loud to
his fellow delegates whether given the
imperfection of human beings with as he
said all their prejudices their passions
their airs of opinion their local
interests and their selfish views given
all that from such an assembly can a
perfect production be expected it was
not perfect but it was Franklin said and
here I quote him so near to perfection
as to make him marvel at its
accomplishment I think Franklin said it
will astonish our enemies who are
waiting with confidence to hear that our
counsels are confounded like those of
the builders of Babel today when all too
much of our own political discourse is
little more than babble it is fitting
that we reflect upon the accomplishment
of America's founders and it is fitting
to that we celebrate their
accomplishment even in the difficulty of
the deliberations over the Constitution
Franklin saw fit to ponder the
possibilities ahead for the country as
the convention came closer to success
Franklin said that the ornamental Sun on
the chair of the convention President
George Washington hoist and such
ways to make a viewer wonder if it was
setting or rising was surely a Rising
Sun although many today see only a
Setting Sun I am happy to report that
our first speaker today the 12th
president of Hillsdale College is of the
Rising Sun sort having served as
director of research for Sir Martin
Gilbert Winston Churchill's official
biographer and then later having
co-founded the Claremont Institute for
the Study of statesmanship and political
philosophy after which he led it for 15
years
Larry Arne has spent a lifetime
reflecting on the demands of politics
and the debt we Tadeo those who founded
our country such reflection on the
sacrifice of statesmanship dr. Arnn
demonstrates vividly in the classes he
teaches on campus on Aristotle on
Churchill on the American Constitution
in noble the student that souls of
students and also helps them become
better citizens one sees in such study
and in his teaching a Rising Sun indeed
I have to say that about the only time
one doesn't see a Rising Sun sort of
person in Larry yarn is if you are a
young man on hills dales campus probably
a freshman and in the College cafeteria
happened to be sitting next to the
female object of your affection and then
unexpectedly you find yourself on the
receiving end of direct queries from the
president of the college as to how you
such an ugly and foolish one as you are
could ever be worthy of the adulation of
your beloved as one it was happy to
number himself among those who have
learned much from our speaker and yet
also relieved that I've never been
subject to his pointed questionings in
the College cafeteria I'm pleased now to
give you the president of Hillsdale
College dr. Larry R
why David or D Bob as we call him is
made to Anna and when she was his
ladyfriend not yet his fiancee yet I
think one of these dinners that a
Constitution Day dinner I once asked her
to stand up and then ask him why he
didn't propose to her they have two kids
now so hey I did that it's a crisis
isn't it before we plunge into that
terrible thing which we're going to fix
by the way I'll just remind you that
life goes on it's the purpose of a free
government for life to go on and back in
Hillsdale life's going on very nicely
right now we're hit we have our biggest
student body ever we didn't mean to but
we have so many applications for our
college now and so many people come back
our retention rates and all that are so
high that we our goal is to have a
student body of 1,200 and then we say to
1300 and right now we're at 1450 and
last Saturday night we played Division 2
sports at Hillsdale College and last
Saturday night we beat the number four
ranked team in the country and football
and
and I'm proud about that because you
probably know it hills that we're not in
the prisoner taking business so so so
all of our football players on Monday
morning just like every other student in
the college got busy trying to get
through the core curriculum which is
more than half of the time at Hillsdale
College and it means that those kids who
did that are smart and hard-working and
don't spend most of their time playing
football and that's not true of every
college that plays football these days
now about this crisis we've had more
than a decade now to get used to it
Churchill said once in the middle of the
Second World War talking about the
bombing of London which by that time had
gone on for three years and you know
that means that you should get up in the
morning and you've been disturbed in the
night by the explosion of your
neighbor's house that's a bad and
Churchill said of it eels get used to
skinning must be terrible to have to
lose all your skin every year but they
get used to it and we're getting used to
this but it's coming to a head it has
two parts one a abroad and one at home
the one a abroad is easy to state we
just had the anniversary of it it's a
combination of things a very radical
kind of ideology has come into the world
for the last 150 or 200 years and the
latest expression of it is radical Islam
and it's like the others it's utopian
it's a kind of Messianic for things to
happen here on this earth they aim for a
kind of heaven on this earth they aim
for everybody to be in conformity or
compliance all over the earth and anyone
who's not as an enemy they don't believe
in the liberal society and I'm going to
say something about that because those
are in crisis too and they think that
they're weak and they may be right about
that and then something's added to them
to make them important because they
wouldn't be without this thing and that
is technology has changed the world so
very much and one of the ways it's
changed
it's really cheap to kill people you can
just do a lot of that now without much I
mean if you just think about the fact
that they knocked down two big buildings
and killed several thousand people with
some airplanes
it's amazing feat in nature to be able
to get that much weight up in the air at
that much momentum and that power can be
used to destroy a building as readily as
it can be used to take people to Omaha
and if that's the nature of the world
and it's a very dangerous world and
those combination of those two things
threaten us all and they will continue
to threaten us all for a long time our
response to danger in the United States
of America has always been to respond
with the principles of the liberal
society and the liberal society is a
marvel there's never been anything like
it
it developed after a long time it's a
product of the civilization that defines
the West the coming together of the
thought in Athens about the right things
for all people in all times and in
Jerusalem the idea of one God for every
human being and those in their best
aspects have given rise to a kind of
society where the governments on the
people sorry exactly wrong and one can
see how that one would get that
backwards these days where the people on
the government's where the purpose of
the government is to protect the people
in their lives where the government is
actually under the regular
administration of the people I mean by
that that it operates at all times with
their consent and they have practical
ways on a regular basis to express or to
withdraw that consent and these
societies have been just absolutely
marvels in what they have achieved
because each one of us in this room is a
product of such a society and the
phenomenon of all of us and I'm told
60,000 people have registered to watch
this thing on the Internet
and I hope they're not all unemployed I
bet they're not
probably most of them are time shifting
but but all of them too right because
the modal American is like us I like to
say there aren't many Dukes and Earls
among us my father was a schoolteacher
and Pocahontas Arkansas the miracle that
he went to college a miracle that he
wanted to nobody did in those days and I
grew up in a house where people like to
read books and the next thing you know I
can go study anywhere I want to I did do
it I went to Oxford for goodness sake I
met my girl brought her home was lucky
see she'd never seen anything like me so
she didn't know it was unusual
that's the liberal society and marked
the point about it it exists it's a it's
Nexus its fulcrum it's sensitive point
is at the place where the government
meet the people because for there to be
a liberal society then private people
must be in control of the government
this is about this conference is about
the Constitution the United States and
that is the greatest device ever
imagined it is by far the most sex a
successful thing of its kind and it's
specific achievement is to sustain over
time a powerful government capable of
standing up to our enemies in the world
capable of keeping order in our land and
yet under the control of people who
spend most of their time doing something
else than being involved with the
government
that's an amazing it's a miraculous
development and it's very powerful this
development because if you just think
about it as I say these ideologies that
torture the world and they're related
these ideologies you know Marxism and
National Socialism their forms of a
common craziness but a lot of these
radical forms of Islam they have
something in common with
and right you know the baddest parties
in the in the Middle East were founded
with the help of the Gestapo historical
fact the the I think he's the uncle of
Yasser Arafat was the Grand Mufti of
Jerusalem his name was Haj Amin
al-husseini and he was a powerful man
and through the Second World War and he
was a Gestapo officer he was in the pay
of the gestapo and there are lots of
photographs you can look him up on the
internet Haj H ata I mean AMI and I all
al husseiny probably not spell that hu
SS ein I look him up because their
photographs of him sitting having coffee
but they don't Hitler these things have
something in common in their their vile
and every time there has been a war
between those organized marshaled
regimes they have been overwhelmed by
the power of free peoples because here's
what happens in a free country I like to
say in our College which is a joyous
place to work and fun and very effective
very successful these days that the
reason for that is that we're all doing
it all the time we have agreed a common
end and it's very difficult to pursue
that end and there's nothing but doubt
as you go about it you never know how to
solve whatever problems coming up
because you never have enough knowledge
to be sure what the problem is but
you're just much more likely to be
successful if everybody's working on it
and by the way to make a little short
contrast it isn't characteristic of
constitutional rule that detailed
regulations are passed at the center and
then handed down and our government as
recently as 60 years ago really had no
apparatus for doing that maybe 70 years
ago fair because I'm getting old and so
is this kind of government
it's powerful because it marshals the
assistance of all because it involves
all it includes all it gets the best
from all give sculpt to all it's a
beautiful hopeful thing and I say
there's a crisis at home because these
kind of societies are in trouble
and it's just it's it's an easy fact the
facts are undeniable in these liberal
societies where as I say the sensitive
point is in the connection between the
government and the people's in these
societies these things are facts these
societies are near the peak there
they're down a little now but they're
near the peak of their historic wealth
they've never been significantly richer
than they are at this moment in ten
years ago they were richer than they had
ever been
they were also richer than any society
had ever been and also it's true that
their government are a larger percentage
of their societies in money spent and
the numbers employed than they have ever
been
and those government's are broke now
think that right the the gross domestic
product of the United States of America
is about fifteen trillion dollars and
federal state and local spending in the
United States of America is about six
point seven trillion dollars which is
about forty percent which means that
every time there's a dollar spent forty
cents is government but the health care
bill is going to shift that balance um
and other things like that are going on
right and at this level right now at
that level of spending the government is
collecting about sixty percent of the
revenues it needs to pay its bills so it
needs additional transfers of wealth to
it or it needs to restrain itself and
these facts are unprecedented
it's just this has never happened in the
Western world since liberal societies
became the reigning thing in wartime
it's true that the numbers got much
bigger but that was different for the
simple reason that it wasn't the
ordinary course of business and this has
now happened in the ordinary course of
business these wars that we are fighting
that are very serious and could could
you know resulted in the death of us all
by nightfall
in this room you know the right thing
happens or the wrong thing that this war
has not really been very expensive you
know compared to World War two or the
Civil War and so it's not the wars that
are driving this it's the ordinary
routine course of business and it's very
hard to see how you work your way out of
this I mean actually we're gonna be told
I guess here in a few minutes because
congressman Ryan's coming but but in
England for example my wife is English
and her sister is actually here in town
today and lives in London very nice
woman and she's always lived in London
she lives in a nice neighborhood and we
got an email from her a few weeks ago
and it was like a report from a war
front there were riots near her home she
had to be careful about going outside
and her daughter our niece who has a new
daughter our grandniece they live nearby
too and of course that means the young
mother's in trouble maybe and the police
watch that happen and what is the
character of these writers you'd think
they'd be like the writers that deposed
Louie to make the French Revolution or
Tsar Nicholas to make the Russian that
is to say starving people people who've
got no hope people who live under the
thumb of an aristocracy who dominate
them until finally hunger and
desperation drives them to the streets
that's not what they're like they're all
people who have shelter and food and
very many of them are people who live
on the public largesse either as
employees of the government who don't
want a cut in their pay or people who
receive transfer payments and so when
one tries to manage this problem that
these governments are very large larger
than they've ever been as a percentage
of the society so that they don't go
broke cutting expenses is very difficult
and it has in many countries led to
violence now that's a heck of a note if
you think and see I haven't really said
anything right now
on one side of the other of these this
question that is to say what what do I
want you probably know what I want but
I'm not talking about that right now
what I'm talking about is the the nature
and character of the societies in which
we live is that they are liberal
societies and they have these
constitutional arrangements they have on
the view that ordinary people all of
them represented equally all of them
should be in control of the society and
the government and for that to happen
the government must be of a limited
scope and it's bigger than it ever was
in this country it approaches half and
it isn't enough and that means the
decision is coming and soon because for
a reason I'll explain here in just a
second it's this issues in certain
political facts and the political facts
are also very evident if our economy is
under stress now terrible stress and you
know it's really funny we were having an
investment meeting at the college and I
want to border the Heritage Foundation
we had the same thing just yesterday
there we were trying to figure out how
to invest the money and finally and you
know we struggle with that all the time
in our college has done really well
it's really
how well is done I think we've lost I
see mr. Patrick Flanery back there he's
the man who knows but he's our treasurer
and he sitting beside Kim cold who used
to be
except Kenny's going to seed now but I
think we lost one point six percent in
the in the Fed pullback since June and
our endowments really good but you worry
about it all the time right
and how are you going to invest because
there are two facts and finally
yesterday I was able to state them with
clarity at least for myself the first
fact is companies are doing very well
and their profits are high and they're
really cheap the stock market is very
undervalued and you know it's just it's
really dramatic too I mean it's a friend
of ours who's an economist over in
Chicago says that the stock market is
undervalued right now by 65% and that
interesting
I even think it's true but there's this
and that's not even very hard to
understand if I were that kind of guy I
think that he could even explain it to
you now
quickly but forget that the other thing
is imponderable and that's the thing
I've been talking about because is Italy
well that's what's the most like it it's
Greek Greece is going to go broke the
answer is it did but is Italy and if
that happens what's going to happen to
the big banks in France which are the
only ones they have they're going to be
nationalized and they did that once
before and that didn't go very well and
is Europe gonna fall apart
and you know how we gonna cope with this
mess because you know another thing
about it is I said that these liberal
societies are strong they are very
strong in war they're just terrible to
deal with right I mean has it been fun
to be a member of al-qaeda in the last
decade you know was was Osama bin
Laden's life rich and comfortable and at
ease after he killed several thousand
Americans the answer is he was founded
from cave to cave by people who are
extremely good at that and they were all
volunteers for the work
and they took great delight and joy in
what they did and they lost comrades and
they mourned them and loved them and
thought after that that their work was
more worthy than it had been before and
then you know finally they found him
that's the end of him they're very good
at that but the other thing they're very
good at is they can really produce
because Lincoln said God made every man
with one head and one pair of hands and
one mouth and the implication was that
the head should guide the hands in the
feeding of the mouth and if you set up a
system like that it's just an amazing
what happens that's never been more
apparent to me than since I went to work
as a college president and a teacher
because the marvelous thing came to me
finally and I hadn't even understood it
about my own education which I ascribed
exclusively to my teachers and now I
still do extensively that it isn't that
you teach them they learn and they have
to work so hard to learn because all
that stuff that you know that you you
know first you were just so ignorant you
couldn't even carry on a conversation of
you know you were alive with tension
trying to understand what the heck this
person was talking about because you
never heard anything like that before at
that moment you're working a lot harder
than that person is because what he's
done is he started out that way and now
he's spent 20 years and 30 years in my
case nearly 40 years trying to figure a
few things out right and that means that
you see in the classroom the labor of
learning is done by the learner and if
they won't do it you can't do it for
them and by the way you love them when
you watch them do it it's fantastic and
you learn it's an iron fact it can't be
changed that there is no such thing and
there can be no such thing as an
entitlement to an education because you
can't be given it by somebody else's
work you can't any more than you can be
given a living
buddy else's work you see and a society
that's organized with the understanding
of that is very productive and if we
leave that understanding then at last
I'll you know begin to talk on one side
of the question I think most so far
mostly I haven't it's hard for me as you
know if you leave that kind of society
you're not gonna produce as much and
it's going to be harder to pay your
bills and then there's going to be more
trouble whereas if you go back every
year Steve Forbes give a talk he's one
of my favorite people you should listen
to him to get a chance because he talks
about the hopeful side he'll talk about
all these debts and then he can prove
with simple math that if we got our
growth rate up a couple of percent that
all these debts would start looking
small because it's they're gonna have to
be paid off over a long period of time
and if you make a small adjustment to
how much you earn then all of a sudden
your capacity to do it is just much
greater and how would you make that
adjustment green jobs is what I think
I say you do too we have political
stresses and they're acute and they go
along with these economic and these
national security stresses because what
should happen but that politics has
become so very intense now and for a
long time the 2000 election was decided
in the courts and you know for them for
eight years everybody said that the
winner George Bush was illegitimate and
that was because the election was so
incredibly close but it came down to 500
votes in a large state and that means
there's pressure right there's
difficulty if you if you look at the way
the health care bill was passed it was
incredibly you know midnight votes and
the Constitution has a way of asserting
itself I'm going to turn to a hopeful
thing in a minute I'm going to explain
how it still does assert itself but at
the time what were they doing right they
lost an election in Massachusetts and
there's these constant adjustments
because the meant the numbers are close
and in the Senate they need an
extraordinary majority because they have
the the institution of the filibuster
and that just means in the Senate they
believe they get to talk all they want
to and that's funny
but on the other hand there are really
two ways to rule and one is reason and
one is force and reason and talking are
synonyms and so it's always been
respected in the Senate that it's hard
to get anything done because they get to
talk a lot you see and so what did they
do they found ways they didn't they
didn't overcome the filibuster but they
found ways by changing the nature of the
bill for it to require a smaller
majority and this was done on several
weekends and at midnight
and after the whole effort was written
off and that means by the way it was
done by people of incredible
determination they meant it you know
Nancy Pelosi said two things and and
they're they're good to compare you the
first one is ugly to my ear and she
should be ashamed of it but the second
one is not the first one and by the way
you can find this first one on the
internet and you can hear her say what
I'm about to say and you can judge for
yourself the tone of what she said a
reporter from CNN asked her what
authority is there in the Constitution
for you for the government to compel
somebody to buy health insurance and she
replied are you serious are you serious
that was her answer there wasn't any
more answer and to my ear her tone
sounds derisory
that's a remarkable reaction for the
Speaker of the House to make on the eve
of doing such a dramatic thing because
by the way she's been in the Congress a
long time she took an oath write uphold
and defend the Constitution the United
States that's what she took and she's
taking it many times are you serious are
you serious she said no I think they
passed the bill on a Sunday afternoon
and I went looked up her speech just
before they voted and of course you know
she wouldn't have bought the thing to
the vote if she didn't know she had the
votes and she said that her speech is
very pretty you can find it right up
just finished a book can its quoted in
the book it'll be out about Christmas
time but it's it's very handsome what
she says she says that today we keep
faith with the authors of the
Declaration of Independence
she said we we get to fulfill the words
that all men are created equal you see
and what that means mind you that means
you know first of all it's just can't be
doubted that she did this and those who
did this they did this for love
they did this because they think this is
a good thing to do right
and once you absorb that information
that means that the disputes we have
among us are very real and that means
that you're only going to get through
them if you can argue through them or
else you're going to fight and you don't
want to fight you want to be able to
reason through this because the
questions are very fundamental now
because what she thinks what the Speaker
of the House thinks is that the
Declaration of Independence demands the
health care bill and there's a tacit
admission that the Constitution the
United States does not permit it and so
she has separated those things you see
and there is a large scholarship grown
up among us to justify her doing that
Joseph Ellis do you know who he is he's
very good he's an academic historian who
writes books that are however popular
people love to read them and I like to
read them he's very good I like him and
it's just that he's foolish and I'll
tell you why you know he wrote founding
brothers it's a very good book you
should read that book but he wrote
lately American creation and that's more
foolish because he says in the book he
says this he says the Declaration of
Independence treats government is an
alien force he says that now the
difference of dependence is about 1500
words long have you ever read it did you
know probably that it's divided into
three parts there's a beginning which is
very beautiful everybody knows what it
says I'll quote it to you when in the
course of human events it becomes
necessary for one people to dissolve the
political bands that have connected them
to another and to assume among the
powers of the earth the separate and
equal station to which the laws of
nature and of nature's God entitle them
there is the birth of the liberal
society in its most beautiful and
brilliant language and that echoes in
the hearts of every free person always
has since the day it was wrote and
always will that's the beginning the end
is an official act sealed with the blood
oath in support of this declaration now
trusting to the supreme judge of the
world for the rectitude of our
intentions we mutually pledge to each
other Our Lives our Fortunes and our
sacred honor are you telling me he's
here no no what are you telling me
that's Kyle back there he used to be in
my class now he works for me and he's
not making any sense to me do you want
me to talk for five minutes
some of this is live and so all of you
who are watching on the internet please
pretend that this tape has been edited
so that's perfect five minutes so ever
notice the contrast between the
beginning of the document in the end
because the beginning of the document is
universal right it's really amazing I'll
give you an example d-bob married Anna
right she's too pretty for him
I married penny she's too pretty for me
that was a very big day in our lives
when we did that and so it wasn't our
spirit on that day our day the day on
which we founded our family
it wasn't our spirit to talk that day
about how everybody does this and when
you do this there's a certain way you
have to behave there are rituals and
forms that you have to follow but of
course all of the talk is about how our
circumstances are really special you
know the best wedding I you know I'm
accustomed to say now when I go to
somebody's wedding that's the second
best wedding I ever saw right you know
you should be better than mine except if
you didn't get to marry penny so you see
we love to talk about what's special
what makes us the thing what makes our
thing the thing right the Declaration of
Penance they're very much in that mood
right because at the end did you know
there was a warrant out for the people
who signed the Declaration of
Independence and it was a hanging
offence to sign it in support of this
declaration we mutually pledge to each
other Our Lives our Fortunes and our
sacred honor right isn't that lovely and
that's the end but the beginning is when
in the course of human events that's any
time it becomes necessary for one people
that means any people to do you know in
other words they started out talking as
if this is kind of routine and there are
rules
and here's how we are going to obey
those rules and that combination of the
universality of the beginning and the
particularity of the end is unique among
political documents and that's one of
the things that makes it the greatest
what comes in between those two things
but a large long series of charges
against the king
and remember I said that Joseph Ellis
said that it treats government is an
alien force we'll remember in the first
paragraph what the Declaration of
Independence is saying is that any
people has a right to form a people that
it starts out by the way with them the
rights of a people not the individual
but then in the charges against the king
you can anybody remember what the first
one is Greg's just a tourist sitting
back there but he knows he doesn't know
soccer dad the first charge against the
king remember he says it's treats
government as an alien force right the
first charge is he against King George
the third he has refused his assent to
laws the most wholesome and necessary
for the public good so one of the
reasons rebelled against him is that
he's not providing the proper kind of
government but if that's true and
remember I'm going to summarize now
because our speaker is here hello
congressman I'm just getting ready to
lambaste you
because you sir have made a bad decision
everybody knows what I'm talking about
so but if you don't stay tuned so if the
Speaker of the House acting by the way
remember from high motives praise her
for that it's not a question of who
wants to do justice it's a question of
what is justice that is the question we
must answer and the consequences are
enormous but what she says is she will
follow the Declaration of Independence
and not the Constitution and then I
quoted historian who says that the
Declaration treats government as an
alien force and he goes on in this quote
to say that the Declaration of the
Constitution are opposite documents but
they aren't and I you know we're going
to have five of these lectures and if
you want to watch the rest of them all
of you out there and all of you here
you'll find out that I'm giving several
of them and that what I do is explain
how the Constitution the United States
is actually written in the Declaration
of Independence and it has three chief
aspects the first is government must be
representative it has to work for us but
also we don't get to be in the
government we can only control it
through elections and because of that
feature the government never has
ultimate authority inside itself nor do
the people who have ultimate authority
ever get to act except through the
government representative government is
fundamental second the powers of
government must be separated if he just
read the charges against the king it
says that he has messed with the judges
and he has messed with our
representative institutions and the
legislators and he's trying to be all
three things of course the court said
opinions make sense God four times and
among the four mentions are one is each
branch of the government supreme judge
of the world maker of the laws of nature
of nature's God divine providence the
lesson being only in the hands of
but all of the branches be combined and
then finally the government must be
limited so that the society can be a
liberal society
he has sent among us swarms of officials
to eat out our substance and oppress our
people it is a form of constitutionalism
that there is then elected sorry then
established in the greatest Constitution
ever written and the two documents are
in fact whenever they speak of rule
synonymous in their meaning and the
great battle is going to be whether they
can be united again now our guest of
honor he's a favorite person of mine and
I'm cranky with him he comes from
Wisconsin you can see his character in
the fact that not long ago friends of
mine asked me to intervene with him
because I was going to be talking with
him to get him to give a speech and I
said these guys really want you to give
a speech you better go give this speech
and he said you know it's deer hunting
season I've never missed that and my
response was so okay that's a good cause
I think he's doing it I think he's like
that he's a father of three he comes
from a little town in Wisconsin his
career is he went to Muhammad Miami of
Ohio a college in Ohio arrival by the
way to be the second best college in the
Michigan Ohio area and I've never looked
at his grades but I bet I could find
them I don't know people go into our
college or not but if he had he'd know
more
he worked for a Jack Kemp and Bill
Bennett there his buddies with Jack the
late Jack Kemp and Bill Bennett and here
still good buddies he learned a lot from
them he worked for Brownback he got
elected to Congress in 1998 now what he
what he they're just two things to know
about him one is what he's done and the
other is what he is and I I might know
what that second thing is I know I know
what he's done if it's true that we're
in a position where the liberal society
may be about to disappear and if it's
true that the sensitive point is in the
is in the scale and scope and nature of
the relations between the people and the
government then what one would have to
understand and know inside and out would
be the way that this federal budget
works and that is surely the most boring
and hideous subject in human history
except that now it's also a dangerous
subject so it's not boring anymore and
the person who learns about it first of
all he's going to have to have a heck of
a mind to be able to know about it but
then second of all he's gonna have to
have courage to speak the truth about it
because to speak the truth about it is
to call for things to be reduced that
have large constituencies in favor of
them and so that's why so many don't
even talk about that subject and this
man has made himself the master of it
you know is as no one I have ever seen
why did he do that I think it's his
character he's a good listener
he's very well-spoken things come easy
to him and yet he doesn't seem to become
arrogant he loves his children thinks
he's working for them refused to run for
president because he's foolish went to
the wrong College
but I was one of those who urged him to
do that and I did that because because
of the right reason I don't know if he
could win I don't I know he's the right
kind and I know when he talks the people
get what they've got coming to them
which is the truth and a chance to
choose about it
welcome the speaker of the truth all
right
Wow
no pressure well thank you very much
Larry
like I said no pressure there what do
you say thank you for that kind of
introduction I really appreciate that
you've been a true friend to Liberty and
to me as well it's always a pleasure for
me to speak here to Hillsdale folks the
mission you had here at the Kirby Center
in Washington is a great example of what
Hillsdale is all about in the words
James Madison Liberty and learning each
leaning on the other for their mutual
insurance support in addition to those
of you who are here with us today I'm
told that these remarks are being
broadcast by webcast for the benefit of
Hillsdale students back in Michigan
where right now it's about 8:30 in the
morning or the most college students the
crack of dawn so your scholarly passion
for human freedom must be powerful
indeed this Saturday we celebrate the
two hundred and twenty fourth
anniversary or birthday of the
Constitution written by the framers in
Philadelphia in paying tribute to this
inspired document I want to talk about
how we should think about the
Constitution and why especially today
this matters usually our defense of the
Constitution is presented as a defense
of Americans founding principles in our
values in rightfully so but our
constitutional system is not just a
collection of principles it embodies an
approach to government with profound
practical implications for both our
freedom and our prosperity when that
system is threatened both freedom and
prosperity suffer freedom is lost by
degrees and the deepest erosions usually
take place during times of economic
hardship when those who favor of
spending the sphere of government abuse
a crisis to persuade free citizens that
they should trade in a little of their
Liberty for empty promises of greater
security well we all remember what
Benjamin Franklin said about that trade
that those who would make it deserve
neither liberty nor security but in such
cases
when liberty is lost it is our fault as
champions of the Constitution for
failing to mount a sufficiently
persuasive and effective defense and I
believe our defense falls short when we
fail to connect our timeless principles
and values to the urgent economic issues
facing the factory worker in Janesville
Wisconsin who's suddenly unable to
provide for his family or in some of
your cases the recent college graduate
who finds herself in one of the worst
job markets in recent history we can
strengthen our defense of Liberty if we
remember to keep in mind those who are
struggling to make ends meet what makes
our Constitution such an extraordinary
document is that in making the United
States the freest civilization in
history the founders guaranteed that it
would become the most prosperous as well
the American system of limited
government low taxes sound money in the
rule of law has done more to help the
poor than any other economic system ever
designed I want to talk today in
particular about the last of those the
rule of law which is absolutely
essential to all other benefits of our
system to the prosperity and freedom of
our country and to the well-being of all
Americans especially the most vulnerable
well what is the rule of law Larry just
talked about it when the Declaration of
Independence cited as justification of
the laws of nature and nature's God the
founders were channeling Aristotle who
wrote that the rule of law and principle
means that quote God and intellect alone
rule
Erol Aristotle defined the law as
intellect without appetite by what she
meant just as untainted by the
self-interest of those in power the
great difficulty we encounter in
striving to meet Aristotle's idea was
best summed up I think by James Madison
if men were angels no government would
be necessary and if angels were to
govern men neither external nor internal
controls on government would be
necessary but as Madison remind us men
are no angels
and the government is administered by
men over men grounded in a proper
understanding of human nature
our founders tackled this challenge
head-on with a brilliant Constitution
and a healthy separation of powers
binding all men to the same set of laws
and preventing any one man or a group of
men from gaining enough power to declare
themselves above the law the
Constitution secures rights long
understood to be essential to the rule
of law such as the right to due process
meaning that the laws of the land must
be transparent consistent and equally
applied to all men so that no man may be
arbitrarily deprived of life liberty and
property this constitutional cornerstone
of our free society is also a critical
precondition to a free and dynamic
society in economy without the rule of
law to safeguard the ownership of
property and the enforcement of
contracts it makes little sense for an
investor to put his capital at risk
helping an entrepreneur to pursue a
dream
to advance an idea and ultimately grow a
business that creates good-paying jobs
for Americans for decades the US economy
has been a magnet for investors
entrepreneurs and workers because we
enjoy some of the strongest and most
transparent legal protections in the
world
these protection provide a stable
environment for business investment
stability that is totally undermined
when the discretionary power of
bureaucrats is enhanced many countries
around the world are remained mired in
grinding poverty for lack of the
institution's necessary to guard
property and contracts from the
appetites of local despots and their
cronies their economies are highly
unstable and the fate of the business
investment is often subject to the whims
of a single person or a small group of
bureaucrats the good news is that the
United States still a Joy's in enormous
edge over most of the world when it
comes to the strength of our
institutions and a reputation for
respecting the rule of law but we are
moving in the wrong direction and we
would be full
to believe that the job treaters of this
country have not noticed that let me
give you just a few examples of how the
rule of law in this country has been
degraded over the past several years and
replaced by the rule of man the first
monetary policy I'm not suggesting that
the Federal Reserve is there anything
the illegal treasurer's or even
treasonous but I do believe that
Congress has delegated far too much
arbitrary Authority to the Fed and that
in recent years the Fed has trended too
far toward discretionary and away from
rules based monetary actions small
changes in monetary policy can have
really big economic consequences and the
central bank can serve as a major source
of economic instability in 1993 Stanford
economist John Taylor developed a rule
to improve the stability and
predictability of US monetary policy an
untold economic success story in the
1990s is the feds adherence to price
stability thanks in large part to John
Taylor's tea insights
unfortunately the Federal Reserve
abandoned the so-called Taylor rule
roughly a decade ago after the tuck
after the tech bubble collapsed and a
growing body of evidence supports the
idea that the Fed kept interest rates
too low for too long throughout the past
decade helping to fuel the enormous
housing bubble that caused the financial
crisis of 2008 the central bank
continues to pursue a misguided policy
of arbitrary decision making that is
contributing to economic uncertainty and
in my opinion causing more harm than
good next energy in an Environmental
Policy I think the Obama
administration's actions here offer a
perfect example of what happens when you
concentrate too much discretionary power
into the hands of unaccountable
bureaucrats
remember in 2007 a wrongheaded Supreme
Court decision cleared the way for the
Environmental Protection Agency to
unilaterally regulate greenhouse gases
if the agency found that such gases may
reasonably be anticipated to endanger
public health or welfare as soon as the
EPA's chief from up the Obama
administration took office reasonably
was unreasonably defined and the agency
issued finding after finding that would
produce real economic harm in exchange
for distant and dubious environmental
lands well with Nancy Pelosi and Harry
Reid then running Congress the
administration first pushed for
legislation resembling the European
Union's cap-and-trade system because of
the EPA's power grab affected industries
face the old good cop bad cop routine
it was either play ball at Pelosi or
else the EPA could be counted upon to
come up with something even worse given
the options it's no surprise that a
who's who of big corporations lined up
to support their bill once their
priorities were met even though most
Americans remain strongly opposed to
this legislation this bill passed the
House but it was unable to overcome
bipartisan concerns in the Senate
cap-and-trade legislation was deemed
costly economically harmful and
ineffective in its means in schools but
instead of accepting this verdict on its
preferred policy the administration
decided to let the EPA carry on with its
harmful plan to impose unilateral
emissions descriptions on American
businesses which raises the question why
does the Constitution establish a
lawmaking body at all well the EPA
has been busy pushing commercially
competitive punishing commercially
competitive sources of energy the
Department of it of Energy under
President Obama's direction has been
acting like the world's worst venture
capital fund picking winners and losers
mostly losers these days by spending
recklessly on uncompetitive alternatives
for evidence look no further than
Solyndra a solar panel company that
recently received 500 million dollars in
stimulus funded loan guarantees
last month Solyndra filed for bankruptcy
and laid off its employees and the story
just keeps getting worse by the day the
federal government's job is to make and
enforce sensible rules of the road so
that markets are fair transparent and
competitive when bureaucracy is
empowered to reward politically
well-connected firms at the expense of
economically competitive ones this
weakens the rule of law it wastes
taxpayer dollars and it makes
sustainable job creation that much
harder to achieve another example we
have seen a lot of damaging economic
adventurism in the area of financial
services lately tarp was supposed to be
confined to a narrow emergency and used
to avoid precisely the kind of situation
I described at the beginning of this
speech an economic calamity in which
politicians promising security in return
for a loss of freedom would do enormous
damage to the cause of Liberty needless
to say it was disappointing when the
Bush administration approved the use of
TARP funds for the bailouts of General
Motors and Chrysler this entrenched the
idea that tarp could be used as a slush
fund for just about any kind of economic
intervention regardless of the fact that
the original bill charged the program to
quote purchases Troubled Assets from any
financial institution that was bad but
the greater damage came later when the
Obama administration used that bailout
to trample the rights of Chrysler
secured bond holders including state
pension funds in order to give
politically favored groups a better deal
than they were entitled to receive under
the bankruptcy law this makes it less
likely that institutions safeguarded in
charge of safeguarding people's life
savings will invest that money in ways
that create jobs in the United States
the dodd-frank overhaul made Financial
Services matters that much worse
dodd-frank involves radical changes to
financial regulation changes that will
affect every feature of our financial
services industry increase the power of
current federal regulatory agencies
increase
new ones for example the FDIC may now
take control of any financial
institution if a panel of regulators
under the Treasury secretary sees a
danger of systemic risk which is up to
the regulators to define more over
smaller institutions do not receive the
protections given to big firms under
this law that result in unequal
treatment as well as higher borrowing
costs compared to their larger
competitors dodd-frank promotes the rule
of bureaucrats to our economic detriment
inviting political corruption while
further degrading self government the
next case involves a troubling overreach
which I'm going to have the pleasure of
voting on in about a half hour that
we've seen from this administration's
appointees to the National Labor
Relations Board
the most notorious case involves Boeing
which the NLRB is suing over its
decision to locate a new factory in
South Carolina instead of union-friendly
Washington states the board's actions
are threatening hundreds of jobs but
this isn't the only example of the
board's overreach early in his
administration the president promised
labor leaders that he would work to pass
a card check bill to make union
organizing easier but just like cap and
trade car check failed in Congress so
the NLRB simply issued new union
election rules that would in the words
of one former board member quote achieve
the primary objectives of card check by
administrative rule without the need for
tough congressional votes unquote again
with agencies like this what do you need
Congress for more generally speaking we
should not be surprised to find
organized labor leading the charge for
more bureaucratic discretion and federal
rulemaking an agency that is free to
broadly interpret its statutory
authority is one that can utilize only
broaden its size and its scope and in
the process it can increase the size and
influence of the public sector unions to
which its employees belong last case the
president's health care law this one's a
doozy
let me share with you a figure that
serves as a devastating indictment of
the new law so far over 1,400 businesses
and organizations have been granted
temporary waivers from the laws onerous
mandates these waivers do not guarantee
relief in the future which is that why I
like to refer to them as stays of
execution nor do they help the firm's
that lack the connections to lobby for
the waivers the powerful discretion
assumed by HHS to play judge in
determining these days of execution does
tremendous damage to the rule of law the
president's health care overhaul
undermines the rule of law and so many
other ways as well
the new law empowers a panel of 15
unelected unaccountable bureaucrats in
Washington to cut Medicare in ways that
will deny benefits for current seniors
the new boards recommendations would
become law unless a super majority voted
affirmatively to replace these
recommendations a high hurdle that
raises constitutional questions about
whether Congress can legitimately grant
this much lawmaking authority to an
unelected agency look I'm not trying to
question the intentions of those who
have decided to make Medicare spending
less accountable to the democratic
process
I think they truly believe that it is
better to let government appointed
experts make these kinds of decisions
free from the checks and balances that
define our messy democratic process but
in weakening the rule of law in the
United States their intentions are
totally irrelevant the damage they have
done is real and the relevant question
we have to ask ourselves is whether as
Ronald Reagan put it we believe in our
capacity for self-government or whether
we abandon the American Revolution and
confess that a little intellectual elite
in a far distant Capitol can plan our
lives better for us then we can plan
them ourselves if we succumb to this
view that our problems are bigger than
we are if we surrender more control over
our economy to the governing class then
life in America will become defined by a
new kind of class war
a class of bureaucrats and connected
crony capitalists trying to rise above
the rest of us call the shots rigged the
rules and preserve their place atop
society and their gains come at the
expense of working Americans
entrepreneurs and that small
businesswoman who has the gall to take
on the corporate chieftain the
Constitution's framers knew that there
is a human inclination to increase
personal power at the expense of law so
they created a congress as decentralized
in an internally divided institution but
they granted at ample authority to
secure the rule of law in every case
Congress holds the power of the pen as
well as the power of the purse it has
the power necessary to address the
attacks on the rule of law in our
executive bureaucracies and even in the
courts the Constitution provides us with
the power to solve these problems what
we need is the will to do it the
solution the defense of the rule of law
will have to involve alternative ways to
address the public problems that too
many of our friends on the Left want to
solve by simply delegating power to
bureaucrats for every government
curtailment of our Liberty for the
discretion of bureaucrats there are
alternative reforms that could address
these same problems within the framework
of the rule of law and indeed they could
address these problems more effectively
House Republicans have proposed a policy
agenda to do just that reclaiming
America's exceptional promise charting a
path not only toward fiscal
sustainability but also to renewed
prosperity restoring the rule of law
reducing the influence of bureaucrats in
the lives of Americans and empowering
them to take more control over their own
lives is central to the budget we passed
earlier this year in fact such reforms
go hand in hand with our efforts to lift
the crushing burden of debt to secure
our social safety net and to spur job
creation and sustained economic growth
for all Americans in monetary policy
Congress must refocus the Federal
Reserve on price stability within a
clear rules based system
because businesses and families alike
needs sound money to invest to grow in
to prosper in energy Congress must limit
the EPA's discretionary power to impose
a unilateral vision of a job destroying
cap-and-trade system in financial
services Congress needs to establish a
regulatory environment that is fair
predictable and reasonable in labor
policy Congress needs to rein in an
agency that is threatening job creation
by overreaching its mandate and to make
sure that we have a public sector that
works for the people it serves
and not the other way around and in
health care we just need to repeal the
president's new disastrous health care
law
that way we will diminish the power of
unelected bureaucrats over the system
and give that power to individuals and
families by advancing reforms that
harness the power of choice and
competition in health care rather than
increasing the size and scope of central
administration let us champion an agenda
guided by the American idea of equal
rights under law let's begin to remove
the hurdles that government has erected
legislative reform should empower people
families and computers in communities
excuse me not bureaucrats and their
cronies the American idea unites liberty
and law in a bond that must never be
severed America can win back the promise
of individual liberty a promise we have
and we have continued to shed blood to
defend but the time has come to honor
our Constitution's limits on arbitrary
bureaucracy and return to the rule of
law to make it the center of our
government look looking out here in the
face of today and knowing that some of
you woke up at the crack of dawn at 8:30
a.m. to watch online I am hopeful I am
confident in optimistic because of
Hillsdale and others that a new
generation is coming to the study of
politics with a real appreciation to the
Constitution and its centrality to
ensuring justice and security in our
communities to promoting the welfare and
prosperity of all people and to securing
the blessings of liberty to ourselves
and for our children by respecting the
rule of law reclaiming the prominence of
our Constitution and reforming our
government I have no doubt that we the
people working together can help ensure
that the next generation of citizens
inherence a stronger freer
more prosperous America and a more
perfect union thank you very much for
having me today
thank you
thank you very much
I thank you I apologize I intended to
stay in do QA but a vote is being called
to rein in the NLRB and to swear in to
new members of Congress and I don't want
to miss those two events all right so
thank you very much I appreciate it
thank you